hey youtubers is Charlie and they just
renewed arrow for season three so I
thought it would be fun to talk about
the top five stories that they should
adapt from the comic books I'm talking
about specifically green arrow stories
they tend to grab from all over the DC
Universe we can always talk about
stories from say like the Batman
universe and other places in a future
video I'm also gonna be doing my top
five flash stories next week be sure to
subscribe to get that video if you're
finding me for the first time I'll also
be doing an arrow video for the top five
characters that they need to bring on
the show next year
hint hint slaves children so just to
preface real quick one of the really
cool things about this announcement is
is that it came really early in the
season we're only about halfway through
typically they don't make renewals until
after a season is over so means the CW
has a lot of confidence at arrow like
six seasons in a movie confidence so
here we go
top five green arrow stories they need
to adapt next year number five road to
Jericho this features the Red Hood Jason
Todd attacking speedy Oliver tries to
deal with them and it eventually turns
into one villain after the other just
tag-team him including Deathstroke
Merlyn brick and Constantine at the end
of the story he also ends up asking
Black Canary to marry him there are a
couple aspects of the story they'd have
to change because a lot of the Batman
characters are legally tied up in Fox's
new Gotham TV show they can use Slade's
son Jericho or even ravager to come
after Roy for revenge in the wake of
whatever's going to be happening in the
season 2 finale we don't know what's
going to happen to slade yet but it's
definitely not gonna end well he won't
die but he will be beaten very badly
this is also an opportunity to bring
Slade's children onto the show of all
the people that they've talked about in
arrow they're the most notable
characters that we have not seen yet and
bringing them on would give us a
backdoor to one young justice and then
to Teen Titans eventually number four
Archers Quest who wants an Oliver
roadtrip it's all about Oliver
reclaiming all these really sentimental
personal items from all over the world
including a lot of family heirlooms they
did a brief team arrow road trip to
Russia this season already you know that
Diggle eccentric episode but it would be
a good opportunity for Roy and Oliver
ramble and man's story it's always fun
to see them travel outside of Starling
city or they could always swap you know
that Roy part for felicity
raise your hand if you want to see an
Oliver Felicity roadtrip just think
about it the idea of them sharing a
motel room which is break tumbler number
three hard traveling heroes who wants a
Green Lantern crossover this is also a
road trips
but it's most notable for being a Green
Lantern crossover story it's Oliver Hal
Jordan and black Canary solving problems
as they travel across the Midwest
you know Jack Kerouac style but think
about it if they changed Hal Jordans
part for Grant Gustin and made it a
flash arrow crossover it'd be so much
fun just imagine them on a road trip
together it's really unclear at this
point what the crossovers next year
gonna look like between the two shows
but it's likely that they'll involve
major villains last year's arrow road
trip story was a pseudo Suicide Squad
story but they could always get Oliver
involved in a rogue's gallery storyline
number two longbow hunters this is where
it starts to get a little bit dark this
actually features an aging Oliver which
they have to fudge just a little bit but
he tracks down the serial killer while
Black Canary tries to take down a drug
circle it's actually the story where
Oliver first meets shadow which
obviously they'd have to change as well
just based on her being dead on the TV
show the reason it's super dark is
because Oliver ends up murdering one of
the villains that he finds torturing
Black Canary arrow kind of did this
during season 2 when count vertigo was
gonna inject Felicity with the mirakuru
so technically the TV version of Oliver
has already gone into that you know dark
territory some changes they could make
would be again you know swapping the
shadow character for say ravager or even
the sin character because Bex
taylor-klaus would actually have a
slightly expanded role next year anyway
they could even swap Oliver and black
Canary's roles remember she's just left
the League of Assassins so she hasn't
really pacified herself in the way that
Oliver is tried to do this year remember
his character is all about not killing
people which is something that sara is
still kind of dealing with she still has
some rage issues and number one cry for
justice this is really dark and a bit of
a long shot but it's super epic Oliver
basically goes nuts in this storyline it
involves Prometheus chopping Roy's arm
off it's a story all about how Oliver is
undone as a person and after his family
and team are decimated right now they're
actually kind of teasing this with
Slade's storyline in present-day
Slade is going to try to destroy
Oliver's life by destroying everything
he loves what they could do that would
be really epic and kind of meta would be
having Oliver across the line going
after villains
you have Amanda Waller send the Suicide
Squad to stop him it would be like the
government going against team arrow I
don't think they'll do something quite
that dark but it would be awesome to see
Amanda Waller and Oliver go after each
other all that being said here is a
bonus choice that's really cool
since arrow borrows a lot of stories
from all over the DC Universe it would
be amazing to see them do look at Days
of Future past
story line with Kingdom Come you could
actually even involve a practical time
travel aspect of the story line via the
flash and STAR Labs maybe something a
little bit more practical than the
cosmic treadmill but it would be just a
story where you have all of our trying
to prevent a much darker timeline from
actually happening it would even be a
way to kill a major character like
Felicity or Thea or even Oliver himself
and then kind of reverse everything at
the end of the storyline so now it's
your turn let me know in the comments
which story do you want to see arrow do
next year from the comic books remember
next week I'm gonna be doing my top 5
Flash stories that they should do on
season 1 of that show and I'm going to
be doing my top 5 characters that arrow
needs to introduce next year there's so
many other people that could come onto
the show don't forget tomorrow to videos
for Valentine's Day I'm doing Hannibal
season 2 and Supernatural season 10
right now click here to learn all about
the arrow flash crossover they're going
to be happening this season as well as
next season in click here to get my
latest arrow Q&A thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives
you